dès 1986 à 1994 l'avis de la rédaction
de tf1 les conférences de rédaction le
journal télévisé les reportages voilà de
quoi parle une télévision française
cette pièce de théâtre raconte surtout
le grand chamboulement de cette chaîne
de télévision sa privatisation en 1987
tf1 une chaîne du service public et le
gouvernement de jacques chirac décide de
la vendre et de la vendre au groupe
bouygues et donc je raconte comment le
groupe bouygues et à transformer cette
chaîne en profondeur la transformer en
une chaîne très performante mais aussi
très commercial et du coup j'analyse un
petit peu avec les acteurs comment tout
ça à modifier les contenus de
l'information une époque de transition
pour l'entreprise le metteur en scène a
voulu réaliser cette pièce puisque tf1
fait partie du patrimoine français j'ai
eu envie que les gens puissent se
retrouver
et avoir un comme un phare tout tu
pouvoir identifier de quoi ça parlait et
donc j'ai pris un peu une chaîne
consensuel grand public puissante pour
raconter et bien l'information
aujourd'hui la création d'une chaîne
d'informations en continu via le groupe
tf1 mais aussi les séries américaines
sont autant de changements pour cette
chaîne se la raconte aussi l'histoire
d'une époque beaucoup d'événements
marquants ont eu lieu je raconte les
élections mitterrand chirac la rivalité
la mort de malik oussékine je parle de
sartrouville aussi les évènements qui
ont eu en 1991 en banlieue là juste à
côté la cité des indes quand un jeune
maghrébin s'est fait tué par un vigile
au japon les premières émeutes trois
heures de spectacle dix acteurs sur
scène des journalistes inventé cette
pièce sera visible également au théâtre
des abbesses à paris durant tout le mois
de janvier